Here's the equation we found. I'm going to rewrite this equation by dividing by
2. I'm going to just change what it looks like. Notice, if I divide both sides
of the equation by 2, I need to be careful on this side. I need to take the 2
and divide it into each term, both the 2l and the 2w. I get p divided by 2
equals l plus w. This p divided by 2 might look funny. But we know dividing by a
number is the same as multiplying by the reciprocal. So, I can rewrite this as p
times 1 half. So, I have p times one half. This should connect to your drawing.
I know if I go half way around the parameter I should only be at l plus w.
Notice, it is l plus w, that's half way around the rectangle. We know the
perimeter of the rectangle is 52 feet so I am going to write that here. The
length of the rectangle is 6 feet more than the width. So, I can write the
length being equal to w plus 6. The length is 6 more than the width. Now, we can
make a substitution. Wherever I see the letter l, I can replace it with w plus
6. And wherever I see the letter p, I can replace it with 52 feet. We have a
half times 52 equals w plus 6 plus w. We made the substitution so we could work
with one equation and one variable. Now, we can actually solve for this one
variable. I'm going to leave that up to you. Enter the width here and the length
here. And don't worry about writing units, I've got those for you.